on va entendre à présent la première
ministre éisabeth
borneè pas encore parti des Invalides
donc je pense que ça effet de très
nombreux citoyens se sont mobilisés pour
répondre à l'App Quié lancé par le
président du Sénat et la présidente de
l'Assemblée évidment cétait important
pour moi d'être là avec mon gouvernement
pour dire que la République doit
protéger tous ces citoyens que ne peut
être inquiété en raison de son origine
et de sa religion et qu'avec le
gouvernement avec tous les ministres
nous voulons dire à nos concitoyens de
religion juif que nous sommes à leur
côté nous sommes mobilisés que nous ne
laisserons rien passer il y aura des
démarches derrière c'est ce qu'a dit le
président Larcher pas seulement une
marche mais des démarches qu'est-ce
qu'il veut dire écoutez le président
Larcher expliquera les démarches qu'il a
en tête moi ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que les policiers les gendarmes
les magistrats sont très mobilisés pour
ne laisser pas
aucun message de haine pour ne laisser
évidemment passer aucune violence à
l'égard d' nos concitoyens parce qu'il
est religion juif donc on est laisse
rien passer on est au côté de no
concitoyens de religion merci m merci
beaucoup